alors avant de continuer sur le chapitre
de miss monde
on va demander des réactions d'une
spécialiste des miss et d'un homme de
religion précise geneviève de fontenay
et l'abbé de la morandais
geneviève bonsoir alain de la morandais
bonsoir montcharmont fiche
comment ça va mon père vient alors
j'aime bien oui vous êtes présidente du
comité miss france alain morand dès
maintenant vous n'êtes plus que curé
d'une paroisse à la gare de lyon mais
votre magistère moral continue à
s'exercer sur les médias français avant
je le rappelle trop les spectateurs qui
ne vous connaîtraient pas vous avez été
nommé nier du milieu politique et vous
avez été démissionnés par jacques chirac
nous pardonnons avant vous pardonner
vous bien et vous êtes l'auteur en ce
moment d'un livre qui s'appelle les
nouvelles fidélité et c'est chez lattès
voilà alors geneviève quand vous
entendez ça c'est infernal
ça m'inquiète parce que je pense qu'on
va aller vers les moments de violence on
a connu mon père c'est des guerres de
religion et les protestants qui
s'étripent et avec les catholiques en
france jamais eu de problème avec la
hiérarchie catholique non non non
d'ailleurs je signale temps 96 leur
bellevue ketty savoyard n'avait eu un
télégramme de félicitations de la part
de l'évêque d'annecy franchir n'aurait
pas que jusque l'homme lui et c'est vrai
que cette histoire du nigeria évidemment
nous ça nous avait interpellés au moment
où j'avais lu dans la presse ça veut
dire england journal que amine al hawa
était condamnée à être lapidée oui parce
qu'elle avait un enfant hors mariage
c'est vrai qu'à notre époque au 21e
c'est quand on voit quand on dit ça on
est on a des frissons en année on est
consterné bon c'est vrai que en
afghanistan j'ai vu j'ai même pas pu
regarder un jour j'en était divisé on a
vu une femme quitte il dort sur le stade
et qui allait avoir la tête tranchée
ouais bon on au bangladesh dont les
vitryats alors passé c'est épouvantable
parce que dans les concours de beauté
justement c'est le trait d'union entre
les peuples en général dans ces concours
il n'y a pas de problème personne se bat
y'a pas de problème il ya des files de
toutes les couleurs à weedon toutes les
religions du toutes les races et les
hommes qui font la guerre c'est les
hommes qui font tout ça bien sûr mais en
même temps de la organisé alors par
collection miss mots voilà alors là
c'est deux jours en juillet
voilà nos amis téléspectateurs les faits
donc l'élection de miss monde devait
avoir lieu le 7 décembre donc c'est en
plein ramadan un à la jack et la
capitale fédérale à revenir chez nigeria
s'était c'est qu'on cite c'est un peu
une provocation et d'aller faire ça dans
un pays où seront 19 8 heures il ya 12
qui pratiquent la charia au début
effectivement les musulmans qui
représentent la moitié de la population
du nigeria ont dénoncé ce qu'ils ont
appelé l'état l'âge indécent de femmes à
moitié nues bon là c'est une
dénonciation dans la presse ça vous
connaissez et puis quand les candidats
sont arrivés ça a fait monter la tension
dans dans tout le pays
et puis surtout faut dire qu'il ya eu un
article d'un quotidien qui s'appelle 6
day qui disaient que mahomet aurait il
fait il aurait sans doute choisi une
femme parmi parmi elles voilà expliquait
pourquoi est-ce qu nigériane depuis 1976
il ya toujours eu des élections nos miss
nigeria qui se sont passées sans
heurtent sans problème parce que
figurez-vous géopolitiquement chez vous
regardez la carte depuis les philippines
jusqu en algérie eh bien il ya les
foyers fondamentalistes qui constamment
allume le feu en passant par les inde le
pakistan à zahlé ni les juges ni chaude
la situation a changé depuis quelques
années vous savez au maroc
c'est bien qu'au maroc en 71 ya eu un
défilé nice maroc puisque la première
c'était tanger en 38 et en 71 les filles
ont défilé en maillot marocain miss
france l'année dernière ont fait un
voyage au maroc ils ont fait dix jours
khadir bon elles sont allées dans des
petites communes des petits villages
c'est vrai qu'elles ont pas été présenté
en maillot une si petite commune
elles ont hésité avec des robes des
petits ensembles tout bon c'est vrai
qu'il faut éviter aussi la provocation
jusqu'à raquel se dire que je dirais le
concours de beauté c'est pas le top
model de l'exemple occidental oui on a
mieux exporter non maintenant oxy'pharm
jeu c'est pas l'idéal mais la dame
attendait
vous êtes dans bâlois les islamistes là
non je dis simplement qu'il faut
comprendre la mentalité moi je me
souviens dans le début du tourisme au
maroc ou en tunisie
on recommande évidemment une certaine
décence sur les plages on n'allait pas
faire des chemises et le que l'occident
les poulains de jean guy les gens
prennent chacun quand on voir un devoir
élémentaire
quant aux logements à visiter avec les
femmes maintenant qu'ils sont considérés
comme des objets sexuels
bon la pédophilie la pornographie la
corruption est tous là l'occident n'est
pas un modèle non plus je suis relancer
sérieusement à la demande et vous vous
pensez que l'exposition comme ça de
femmes en maillot sur des podiums à la
télévision c'est la marchandisation de
la femme
j'ai toujours un risque moi je ne suis
pas tout à fait du côté des féministes
lorsqu elles prétendent que leur corps
seul leur appartient qui sera mais dans
le cas de cette marchandisation comme
vous le dites vous-même ya un risque
évident les hommes maintenant aussi
hommage un sens très beau et noble de la
sexualité j'ai pas envie qu'il soit
abattu
mais moi aussi moi tout le monde cherche
est d'accord là
alors michel est ce que vous êtes quelle
position vous par rapport à tout ça je
ne supporte pas l'idée d'avoir eu
justement d'aller organiser cette
manifestation là bas ça je trouve que
c'est très grave
je ne comprends pas que quelqu'un n'est
pas arrêter enfin je veux dire il ya eu
200 morts je permis je termine
l'histoire dont il ya eu cet article
dans le journal
donc effectivement ils ont mis le feu au
siège du journal un cadenas et puis
après il ya eu des églises brûlé des
mosquées brûlé il ya eu 200 morts
il ya une fatwa contre la journaliste
qui s'appelle idioma daniel mais ce que
je pense cependant c'est que le le chef
d'état nigérian vous laisse faire de la
pub en fait au départ c'était pour
montrer qu'ils ont fait ou en verre
voulait corriger l'image de marque à
cause de la charia mais quand ce qu'il
faudrait dire à propos des
fondamentalistes musulmans et pour tout
ce qui se passe au nigeria au soudan on
héritera il ya en ce moment
les victimes sont pas les musulmans sont
les chrétiens moi je suis de la
génération de la guerre d'algérie je les
pendules et mes frères musulmans qui
étaient torturés d'action contre la
torture j'ai défendu ensuite les harkis
parce qu'ils étaient abandonnées c'était
des frères musulmans moi j'attends
aujourd'hui que des frères musulmans
défendent les chrétiens innocents
assassinés parce qu'il ya la place
et j'entends parler voix je les entends
pas c'est vrai quand il a commencé aux
philippines dont l'indonésie à kazan et
personnes s'étaient vu sa personne ça
fait ce bel hymne dans le journal le
monde l'après-midi ouais c'est vrai
termes mêmes de c'est nous qui avons en
somme
en somme braqué le phare de la presse
sur ses dix geria parce que quand on a
vu ça dans les journaux moi j'ai dit
miss france n'ira pas dans un concours
qui se déroule là-bas et c'est ça qui a
déclenché tout malheureusement donc les
miss sont toutes parties 1 en vitesse et
puis maintenant elles sont réfugiés à
londres où aura lieu l'élection le 7
décembre
enfin disons que moi j'ai dit toujours
oui aux canons de la beauté nom assez de
la guerre qui tue et qui vont encore tué
au
plus jeune je meurs
lucas ou une paire de thierry j'invite
miss maroc à être à l'élection de miss
france à lyon 14 décembre et dans le
jury très bien